senator Bernie Sanders is now making
headlines because he's in no uncertain
terms calling for the resignation of
President Trump this is another voice
one of the more prominent voices that's
calling for Trump's resignation after
the numerous resignations related to
allegations of serial sexual assault of
women he and Democratic senator Kirsten
Gillibrand and many others are now
saying listen Al Franken resigned Roy
Moore was repudiated insofar as he lost
on Tuesday we've seen other resignations
it's time for Donald Trump to resign now
what's interesting is that Bernie
Sanders is making headlines for this now
even though he's actually been saying
this for some time but I guess given the
political climate and the recent news
stories it's getting more attention
here's Bernie Sanders saying this on CNN
there has been a growing number your
Democratic colleagues who call for
president Trump's resignation over
allegations of sexual assault I know you
haven't gotten that far in the past I
wonder are you willing to go that far
now do you think the president should
resign
no I look that's what I said what I said
you know an Al Franken announced that he
was going to resign and I was asked on a
TV show my view I said look Franken
apologized for what he did what he did
was inappropriate he apologized and they
said I think I have to resign you got a
president who has been accused by many
many women of harassment to say the
least this is a guy who was on a tape
seen by everybody in America essentially
bragging about his sexual assault of
women do I think under those
considerations of Al Franken resign do I
think the president should resign I do
though I think he will I don't but yes I
do think he should resign crazy Bernie
with his wacky ideas the White House
through press secretary Sarah Huckabee
Sanders just a delightful human being
she is continues to say all the women
are just lying there just not telling
the truth
and I really have split thoughts about
the resignation thing on the one hand I
do believe that Trump would do anything
possible to avoid getting impeached and
that includes resigning in advance of
that but on the other hand based on what
we've seen Trump do so far I can imagine
him caught holding a gun with dead
bodies littering the floor around him
and he'd say it was fake news the
pictures were doctored and still not
resigned
but the good thing here is the pressure
right the pressure is building for Trump
to go on three different reasons there
are three completely separate areas of
pressure being placed on Trump to go
number one more than a dozen sexual
assault allegations from women over a
period of decades none of which have
been disproven merely just called lies
as a sort of blanket statement by Trump
and Sarah Huckabee Sanders and pressure
is building on an investigation about
those dozen plus accusers of Donald
Trump that's number one number two we've
got the Russia investigation right which
is getting closer and closer to Trump
every single week we've got four
indictments two guilty pleas already
every week we learn more about what
seems to indubitably be Donald Trump's
knowledge of what was going on which
ultimately may be proven beyond any
doubt that's number two and thirdly
you've got the growing concern over
Donald Trump's cognitive state and
possible cognitive decline and dementia
which would under the 25th amendment
justify the removal or resignation of
Donald Trump just one of these three
angles could take down a president but
of course Teflon Don no guarantee that
any of them will and the problem is that
he's claiming innocence in all of these
I mean with the sexual assault
allegations doesn't know the women Al
Franken admitted to some of them all
Trump is saying said he's saying he
didn't do it Michael Flynn may have
pleaded guilty but Trump is not going to
yeah and then the last one there I mean
Trump's doctor says that he's the
healthiest president we've ever had
healthiest he went to Wharton his uncle
knew about nuclear which is very serious
and all that stuff yeah so he's denying
all three of these but no doubt about it
there are three paths here and like I've
been saying before the best path for
Democrats might not be any of these
three it might be vote them out in the
midterms and then crush Trump and
Republicans in 2020 and it's sort of
starting to get going now right just to
be super clear with you we're less than
eleven months from the midterm elections
and under three years from the 2020
election it is time to get moving now
and early in 2018 we're going to start
talking about some of the key midterm
races you can get involved in and in
fact I'm going to talk about one
possible race on tomorrow's program but
to go back to Bernie and his call for
Trump's resignation the Trump
want to write this off as political
nonsense don't be confused it's not
normal to have multiple members of the
opposition party in a serious and sober
manner calling for the resignation of
the President of the United States the
left is going to be portrayed as just
being partisan bomb throwers and calling
for the resignation it's not normal to
have this degree this early in a
presidency of opposing elected officials
calling for the resignation of a nurse
and Democrats know what the results are
of impeaching Trump - it's just putting
Mike Pence or maybe put right in there
they're not gonna get their own guy in
charge no doubt about that the video you
just watched was made possible by
support from you please go to
patreon.com slash david pakman show you
can make a pledge of as little as $1 per
month and every dollar helps to support
the work that we're doing particularly
in light of the YouTube ad boycott which
has been really bad